hello everyone and welcome to another
game between these two fine gentlemen is
the world chess champion magnus carlsen
against his uh challenger yanni palmishi
the world chess championship starts in
two days and today was uh the the
opening ceremony if you guys haven't
seen that i will put a link to it in the
description below it will be the first
thing you're you're going to see uh last
some some half an hour maybe 20 20
something minutes it's not a great
opening ceremony but it's not a terrible
one so you know they're you know asking
some questions uh
uh replying so uh you know maybe you
guys will enjoy that there are a couple
of uh final remarks so you know you
would not be throwing away half an hour
if you checked it out so do check it out
if you have like nothing better maybe to
do uh but this game it's from the 2017
london chess classic magnus has the
white pieces and it's the last classical
game that jan won against magnus uh
because everyone has been saying that uh
nipple has a positive score against
magnus of course uh he won four
classical games magnus only won one
classical game so that's gonna
be very very important in the world
championship match because now we don't
have 12 classical games we have 14
classical games but this was in 2017 and
in december so a lot a lot of time has
passed um uh uh sin since uh and it's
it's a question whether this is gonna be
uh important uh what is important i
think is that magnus won at least one a
classical game against nipple in his
entire life so he's not going into the
world church championship match against
someone who he's never defeated like for
example when bobby fischer played
against boris posky uh fisher never
defeated spawsky uh up until the the
wheelchair championship match so it's uh
one second that i think will be
important but let's check it out and
let's see what happened uh as this is
this was 2017 so i wasn't really
covering uh you know every tournament
back then like i i do now
mostly uh but yeah let's check it out
and then we're gonna discuss it a little
bit more so magnus with the white pieces
opens with knight to f3 uh he goes
further at the opening and nipple goes
for c5 this is sort of a sicilian
invitation to direct saying that okay if
you want to play e4 then we play the
sicilian you know and we settle this
like like real players but magnus plays
c3 and this is a very rare continuation
usually you're gonna go something like
c4 or maybe g3 or e3 but c3 is very very
rare uh we have d5 by nipple uh grabbing
the center and now d4 striking in the
center uh we have c captures on d4c
captures and the knight to c6 now we
have knight to c3 and knight to f6 both
players develop all of their knights and
bishop to f4
now nepal goes after the bishop right
away we have knight to h5 and now comes
bishop back to d2 so white loses the
temple with the bishop but black also
lost the temple with the knight
so knight back to f6 and this is um a
very tricky move because uh here nipple
is saying uh if you play bishop back to
a f4 i'm gonna repeat knight to h5 and
you have the white pieces so if you're
happy with a draw like this uh you know
i i would be very happy even though they
have this silly rule where you can't
draw uh before the the 30 move mark but
i don't know if it's illegal to repeat
the move like 27 times and then you know
you reach the 30 move mark but okay
magnus of course doesn't repeat he goes
e3 and we have e6 now bishop to d3 both
players just continued development
bishop d6 we have e4 now uh still
waiting with castles uh d captures an e
for knight captures and the bishop back
to e7 now you do not want this bishop
captured of course uh
giving up the bishop pair you have to at
least
get something for it we have castles by
magnus and castles by nipple and now uh
queen to c2 and it is now as of move 313
that this position has never been
reached again uh so let's see how nipple
continues we have h6 uh taking away that
the g5 square from all of
magnus's pieces we have rook 8 to d1 and
now kind of offering this pawn on d4 but
not really the the
thing is if you capture the d4 pawn
we're going to play knight captures and
now after queen captures we play bishop
to c3 and now you have so much pressure
on this f6 tonight the queen cannot keep
an eye on the knight you have to move
the queen and now we're simply gonna
trade everything captures captures
captures and captures and now uh okay
you want some material but um your king
side is ruined and if we can you know
get some rook lifts in it's gonna be
very hard for black to defend this so of
course nepal not interested in that pawn
he just continues developing bishop to
d7 and now a3 not allowing any future
knights to be four ideas we have rooked
the c8 by nippo uh very nicely played as
the queen is on c2 so there might be
some
useful discoveries whoops with with the
knight
and now knight back to c3 so now you
don't have to worry about knight
jumping anywhere uh we have a6 preparing
b5 at some point and now queen to c1 and
here uh it's a sort of a sort of a trap
because uh well there is pressure on the
h6 pawn and if nipple just continues
with b5 which kind of was the plan then
you can actually capture on h6 and if g
captures queen captures uh it's not a
very pleasant position for black um
for example rook to e8 knight g5 in and
you you're getting destroyed there's no
defense against the bishop to h7 check
so yeah you have to be very careful
nipple plays rook to e8 and now it's a
little bit different now you freed up
the square for the king and now bishop
captures an h6 uh isn't all that
impressive because now captures captures
even bishop to f8 is not possible uh
just chasing away the queen and you've
just added another defender successfully
queen h4 bishop g7 and not much to worry
about here now the king has the f8
square available and that's it white
sacrificed for nothing so after rook to
e8 magnus continues rook after e1
and now we have bishop to f8 now
clearing the e file for the rook and the
bishop is also nicely placed for for
defending purposes
and the magnus now plays bishop to f4
now you still have a lot of pressure on
that h6 pawn but you also claim this
diagonal so this bishop is now a very
good piece we have b5 nipple continues
with his uh expansion on the queen side
and finally queen to d2 magnus removes
the queen from the from the c file and
the queen is a little bit safer now uh
we have b4 chasing away the knight now
or uh forcing white to capture with the
a pawn we have eight captures knight
captures and now the bishop on d3 is
attacked and one one might expect
you know the bishop just to retreat to
b1 but not magnus he just plays knight
to e5 and now this knight is excellently
placed uh he's saying okay capture my
bishop i don't mind and nepo grabs it we
have knight captures on the three queen
captures and now
uh nepo has the bishop pair but for the
moment it's not doing all that much
whereas carlson's knight and e5 is an
incredibly impressive piece plus also
the a6 pawn is hanging so how will you
deal with this well uh nipple decides to
defend it by advancing it a5 now the
pawn is defended on a5 and maybe later
on you can push put the rope behind it
and maybe even advance it even further
so queen to f3 by magnus now putting
pressure on this f7 pawn and bishop to
b4 not allowing this knight to move as
the rook is on e1
and now the question is what do you do
here with white well there's the
question of actually capturing an h6 is
this a possibility or not uh the move uh
of course it's a possibility uh but it's
a very complicated one and the point is
that if bishop captures an h6 g captures
an h6 then white of course would be very
happy white would play knight to e4 and
there's not much black can do you can't
really move the knight the knight is
attacked twice because the queen
captures an f7 and if you bring the
bishop to help out with the defense we
can even play d5 and this is just a very
very uh tough for black there's really
no good move here for example captures
captures now even the bishop is hanging
because the knight will not be able to
capture the f7 pawn hangs and if you
defend it we just add another attacker
to the d file and now black's position
just falls apart the problem with this
bishop captures an h6 move is not g
captures on h6 is bishop captures on c3
so you remove one of the defenders and
only after this
but magnus doesn't have to capture
magnus can even force this with bishop
captures in g7 and now we get
this beautiful position king captures on
g7 queen to g3 check king to f8 and now
b captures on c3 and now magnus would be
down a piece
but it's uh it's well not at all
pleasant to play this for black for
example
uh how do you how do you continue uh
with anything here best for black would
be to be play something like bishop to
a4 attack the rook and after the rook
moves trade off
on another one of carlson's attackers
for example captures capture so now you
get this position where
uh it's hard to evaluate uh white uh uh
the engine says white is is okay here
maybe even better but um you know
playing this uh probably isn't all that
uh straightforward because how do you
advance anything here the bishop will go
to c6 you can start advancing your past
pawn and it's not like you have anything
anything concrete here so this would be
one way to play this with white but
magnus played rook to e3 first he wants
to
have the rook lift ready before he
sacrifices the bishop but now nepo
captures in c3 b captures and now bishop
to a4 chasing the rook away from the d1
square and now magnus plays rook to a1
uh rook to c1 would be a little bit more
precise because uh not only are you well
preparing to maybe push the past c pawn
but also you are preventing bishop to c2
this is nepo's real plan of why bishop
to a4 was played he wants to play bishop
to c2 and then gain control of this
diagonal and use the bishop to help out
with the defense so rook the a1 was
played now comes the bishop to c2
preparing to bring the bishop back we
have h3 and now bishop to f5 and now he
has another defender here
magnus attacks it with the g4 we have
bishop back to h7 and now c4 magnus
starts pushing his pass pawn and he's
offering the d4 pawn but it's not all
that simple to grab this pawn if you
grab this pawn then the idea is that
we're just going to take away the d8
square from the black queen so you
cannot defend the knight so rook a to d1
would be played and now after the queen
moves now we play bishop captures on h6
so that's the idea if pawn captures we
can capture the knight on f6 so after c4
we have the immediate knight to d7 yep
again not interested in any pawns
and now what do you play here
well the uh the absolute best it would
seem is just c5 so that's what maybe
magnus should have gone for knight
captures bishop captures uh and now uh
white's position is great you have a
pass pawn you have a defended pawn on d4
black will play some like bishop to g6
and you can't really do anything about
any attacks on the king side but it's
it's still a game and the white
shouldn't have any problems here however
magnus played knight to c6 and it seems
like uh a great move because you're
attacking the queen and also attacking
the a5 pawn twice but it only seems that
way
because nipple goes queen to f6 and now
magnus does grab the pawn but now knight
to b6 putting pressure on the c for pawn
and how do you defend here
well it's it's not easy because this
spawn is now hanging uh the the c4 pawn
is also hanging so what do you play here
uh probably something like rook the b3
would be best or rook eight to e3 but
here magnus played c5 and it seems like
it should be working but it's uh it's
not and there's a very good reason why
uh so of course uh everyone can see the
rook capture spawn captures queen
captures uh rook on a1 so what is
carlson's idea behind c5 well his idea
is that he saw one move further than his
opponent uh but that's not really true
so this is what happened rook captures
on c5 of course nipple played this we
have d captures on c5 and now queen
captures an a1 with check we have king
to h2 and now nipple also grabs the
knight on a5 but now magnus doesn't
capture here because i mean why would
you then the queen captures and you're
just down a pawn magnus plays queen to
c6 now he puts more pressure on the
knight he's preparing to bring
this spawn into the game of course you
can't play rook to b8 the b8 square is
guarded by the bishop
and the rook on e8 of course is hanging
so what can apple play here there is
only one move that wins this for him
feel free to pause the video and try to
find it while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on helping nepo win a
game against magnus for the last time
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is queen to a4 that's
the good stuff you defended the rook on
e8 and also you put pressure on the
bishop on it for the bishop on f4 is
undefended and there's really nothing
better here than to trade queens the
problem is if you trade here with queen
captures on b6 we simply capture here
with check and after something like king
g1 rook b8 is deadly there is nothing
white can do here rook to b1 check is
coming and the wife has no compensation
for the sacrificed piece so of course
magnus had to capture on a4 nipple
captured on a4 and now c6 magnus started
pushing the pass pawn but now knight to
b6 we have c7 and now uh f6 preparing e5
to
disconnect the bishop's defense of the
opponent c7 rook to b3 going after the
knight but here just knights the c8 and
it was in this position on move 40 that
magnus carlsen resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
i don't know if uh this uh maybe c5 move
was a blunder or maybe uh magnus just
missed that queen to a4 move uh
at the end of this line uh because you
can still play this this game isn't lost
but after c5 it's definitely lost
probably what magnus missed was uh all
the way here this queen to a4 move uh
that connects with the undefended bishop
on f4 it's possible not something that
you know he he should miss but uh you
know anything is possible in inches i
guess uh so yeah after a night to see it
of course you resign because there's not
much you can do uh you have to be
careful uh if you play something like e5
here then then then you would lose for
example captures captures and rook to b8
this is winning but after this uh just
you know moving the knight back there's
really no more compensation and well it
would be pointless to play this
uh so yeah that's the last game nipple
won against magnus it was in uh on
december 8th 2000 and
2017 these are the final standings of
this london chess classic so let's check
it out uh so uh it was a time between
fabiana quran and yanipanishi fabi won
with some better additional criteria
magnus got third place with five out of
nine magnus maxim and wesley also on
five out of nine with four and a half
hikaru levon uh with four three and a
half sergey karjakin anand and michael
adams with with three out of nine uh so
there you have it very impressive
performance by nipple so we'll see this
is uh like i said uh so nipple does have
a positive score against magnus but uh
you know in the in the last four years
that's not really the case in the last
four years it's magnus who has a
positive score against nipple so this is
probably something that should be taken
into consideration not that the games
that were played uh
all the way back you know when they were
like 13 and 14.
uh so yeah uh also something maybe to
take into consideration like i said if
you guys haven't do check out the press
conference the first link in the
description below and uh yeah
tomorrow's a sort of a res day or the
media day as they call it uh and then
the day after tomorrow the world chess
championship starts so we're probably
gonna you know throw in a few more games
uh before that starts and then it's uh
two weeks of world chess championship um
uh fun for for everyone uh so yeah once
again hope you guys uh enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank igor pd jain uh
constantin krangano
gorget is a good lad and we will find a
boat pito uh for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing uh you know at the coverage
of uh well whatever we're covering here
on this channel checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh in this
case the world church championship thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day